why why do you open a Heretics Manifesto
with an essay called her penis and what
is the the main point that you're
driving at there yeah so I I as soon as
I thought to myself I'll do a collection
of essays and call it a Heretics
Manifesto I knew from the first day that
the opening chapter would be called her
penis and at the open in line to the
whole book would be we need to talk
about her penis
um because I find those two words
fascinating I find that the way in which
they've become accepted speech you see
them in newspapers the times here in
Britain which is our newspaper of record
the BBC you know renowned for its
publication of Vital Information to
people around the world those Outlets
will say her penis you hear that phrase
in courts of law if a biological male is
charged with rape or sexual assault and
he now identifies as a woman he people
will say she used her penis to do a b
and c
um I'm fascinated by how a two-word
phrase like that enters the mainstream
enters the public Consciousness how does
that come about what are the mechanisms
through which a phrase that would have
made no sense to us 10 years ago become
a part of everyday conversation and the
argument I make in that chapter is that
this is this speaks to the essence of
the new culture of intolerance I think
because I think one of the key problems
today is the manipulation of language as
a means of manipulation manipulating
thought this is a point George Orwell
made many many times 1984 is basically
about this phenomenon that if you change
language if you change the words people
use and the phrases people use you can
change how people think you can change
how they relate to one another and how
they engage with Society itself so I use
her penis as an example of a change in
language that is designed I think to
change change how we think about sex
gender and the relationship between the
sectors and I find it a bit slippery in
a bit authoritarian so you find her
penis a little bit slippery yeah
um can I ask what what are the stakes
with something like that because I you
know I I agree with you the the kind of
I wouldn't say manipulation of language
but the insistence you know that certain
phrases just you know enter the parlance
and oftentimes you know it might come
from an authority uh you know that is a
cultural Authority or a religious
Authority or a governmental Authority
and sometimes it's risible you know when
uh you know the French Academy tries to
police the use of English phrases in
French and it just fails because
ultimately you can't contain that in
other cases you were talking about in
the past where you know if you said
certain things you would be put to death
because even if it had no clear impact
on the world because it's heretical or
whatnot what are the stakes with you
know acknowledging a trans trans woman's
PR you know preferred pronouns
um
I think the stakes are pretty high
actually and I've had many arguments
with libertarian friends of mine maybe
we'll have an argument now
um which I I love to do because it's a
really good way of working things out
um because I don't see the trans issue
as an issue of freedom and I think
there's a number of reasons I would say
that the first is if this is a civil
rights movement if this is a movement
for greater Liberty which is how it's
often presented why does it feel so
authoritarian why is it so angry why is
it so intent and determined on silencing
women who have the wrong opinions and no
platforming certain people and
um getting people sacked or shamed or
publicly harassed for daring not to use
preferred pronouns and and instead
sticking with what would have been the
right pronouns a few years ago so why
does it have that authoritarian streak I
find that very interesting
um and it's particularly hostile to
freedom of speech and freedom of descent
and on this issue but then the other
thing is I think
it I I often compare it or contrast it
really with the movement for Gay
Liberation in the 1970s which I do think
was a movement for freedom and I talk
about it in the book I think it was one
of the great steps forward in Western
Society over the past few decades
alongside uh the women's Liberation
movement uh the fight for racial
equality and so on
um because I think with the Trans issue
what's happening is that sadly I don't
think trans activists are actually
calling for Freedom they're calling for
recognition they're calling for
validation and they're actually
enslaving themselves in some ways
they're making themselves the psychic
slaves of uh the modern State and the
medical establishment upon whom they
increasingly rely for validation so I
actually think it's a movement that
binds people into a closer more
authoritarian relationship with the
powers that be with power structures
particularly medical structures of power
uh and making the cry you know leave us
alone the great Cry Of The Stonewall
riots in New York City was get the hell
out of our bars leave us alone let us do
what we want to do this says something
quite different yeah
um I I think that's fascinating at the
same time I'm thinking of you know in in
American history and you know
proclamations or demands for racial
equality uh you have somebody like
Sojourner Truth demand saying ain't I a
woman she you know uh you have uh you
know people like Frederick Douglass who
shows up in your book a couple of times
and who's you know just a phenomenal
historical figure that everybody wants
to claim because he's really great at
articulating so much and I want to come
back to him in a little bit but um you
know they're they're part of it is a
demand to be left alone right like that
the state does not have the right or or
a religious community or your neighbors
have a right to poke into you know what
you're eating or what you're sleeping or
what you're smoking or ingesting but
part of it is a demand for recognition
uh blacks in the Civil Rights era would
wear sandwich signs saying like uh you
know ain't I a man and things like that
I'm Black and I'm a man and they were
insisting on recognition is recognition
itself the problem
um or is it something more than that
well I mean the first thing to say about
that is that where that to the extent
that that was a demand for recognition
in the Civil Rights Movement it was a
demand for recognition based on
universal truths ain't I a man yes you
are an entire woman no you're not and
and so that's that's makes it a very
very different question because then
we're talking about you know the guy
with the Sandwich Board saying entire
man he is liberating himself from what
we can all now agree were
structures of racial discrimination and
authoritarianism which made his life
palpably worse than it should have been
I think very often what trans activists
and I do make a distinction between
trans activists and trans people I think
most trans people just want to live a
nice normal life free of persecution and
free of Shame and they should be
entirely at Liberty to do that but I
think what trans activists are often
calling for is not freedom from
oppression but freedom from truth
freedom from the shared understanding
and the shared language that makes life
possible in a in a diverse society and
can I can I push on that a little bit
though because the truth and you know
it's funny because you are I think uh
either a still a Marxist or a recovering
Marxist and I'm a Libertarian postmodern
so we you know you know we've got some
explaining to do to our own sides but
isn't part of what is you know
recognized as true is changes over time
and you know there was a period of time
where blacks in America certainly I
think this is obviously also true that
British Empire
um you know the blacks and to some
degree Irish we we share an Irish
heritage as well you know we're not seen
as human or as fully human in a way and
you know that the science behind that
didn't change what happened was a
political or a social or cultural and
you know uh change happened and I guess
when you say you don't you're not
talking about being anti-trans like
you're you're not against I'm assuming
you're not against adults deciding to
identify as or live as or have gender
reassignment surgery or hormone therapy
whatever to live as whoever they want to
be right I mean you're not saying like
the you know because what has been
creeping into at least in an American
discourse is a kind of a lemon
eliminationist rhetoric where it seems
to start sliding from saying you know
it's one thing to say I identify as a as
a woman so now I'm going to compete in
sport you know in in female sports
categories to you know and people being
being upset about that to saying like no
trans people are the problem you're not
in that camp are you no absolutely not
and I mean I do make a distinction
between hormonal interventions and
surgical interventions in children which
I think is an incredible problematic
thing
um even with parental consent it's a
it's a very problematic thing and adults
I think adults should be completely free
to make alterations to their body to
change to to ask people if they will use
certain pronouns to change their names
to wear whatever they want to to live as
a woman
um as they understand it absolutely they
must be free to do that the
self-government means nothing if people
are not free to Define themselves yeah I
think oftentimes when people get on a
kind of high horse about pronouns and
why not I or names for that matter I
think there's you know a a phenomenal
moment in the 1960s when Muhammad Ali
you know a boxer born Cassius Clay had
changed he became a member of the Nation
of Islam and changed his name from
Cassius Clay to Muhammad Ali and Floyd
Patterson uh also a black uh boxer a
former heavyweight champ fought him and
refused to call him Cassius Clay or
rather to call him Muhammad Ali he
insists and they had a fight and Ali
pummeled him badly and was standing over
the unconscious body of Floyd Patterson
saying you know what's my name and that
you know I think about that as an
incredible Act of reinvention
um and of you know the kind of
self-definition and self-liberation
obviously there's a lot wrapped up in
that and on some level I get
uncomfortable and I'm not lumping you
into this category with people who are
like I will never either say or call or
admit that this person is living as you
know who was born a man is living as a
woman or vice versa and that strikes me
as
problematic to say the least or you know
in a liberal Society you don't want to
compel people to do anything or believe
certainly believe anything they don't
want but it's also kind of like what is
wrong with you
um that you cannot meet adults where
they are I I think there's a couple of
issues there I think on one important
fact I think is that the trans movement
again distinguishing that from the from
trans people the trans Lobby I think
overplayed its hand that's one of the
huge problems here I think if we went
back 10 years people were perfectly okay
most people were perfectly okay with men
who said that they were women who wore
certain clothes who had sex change
surgeries you know there was a bit of a
kind of um a voyeuristic interest in
those Lifestyles but generally people
were okay with it
um I think they overplayed their hand
though because what happens subsequently
is they said trans women are women you
have to legally recognize that we are
literally women otherwise you're a bigot
otherwise you're someone deserving of
cancellation they said we want to play
in women's sports we want to go into
women-only areas we want to go into
women's changing rooms we saw a case
like that in Los Angeles a couple of
years ago a man with a semi-election in
a woman's Cajun room in front of in a
place where women and girls undress and
that's the point at which I think lots
of people said okay hold up what's
happening here because what is presented
as a movement for Freedom looks
increasingly like an encroachment into
the hard-won freedoms of womankind and
so that absolutely raises a question of
a conflict of interest and I do think it
falls down to the question of whose
rights do we support do we support the
right of a man a biological male most of
whom are intact now sex change surgery
is is less and less common right
um to go wherever they want regardless
of the impact it might have on the women
in that area or do we support the right
of women to their own zones their own
sense of safety their own uh sex-based
rights that is I think a fundamental
question and I do think it's important
to stand with the women who are saying
look we don't have a problem with trans
people we just don't want biological
males in our spaces yeah and at what
level because this is something it seems
that you know as heated as the rudder
can be in the United States it's it's
much more
uh sharp in uh in the UK
um and you know part of this is because
JK Rowling is a uh you know is a British
subject and has really become a kind of
poster child for uh you know somebody
who is just uh you know inexcusably
retrograde to the to the degree I mean
this is fascinating that um you know
literally the children who were in the
movies based on the Harry Potter books
almost with ex with that exception I
mean I think the actor who played Draco
Malfoy of all people was the only one
who's like siding with JK Rowling so
it's like okay you've got the punk of
Slytherin house you know on your side
what good does that do you when you know
Harry and Hermione and Ron Weasley are
denouncing you
um some of the you know from what I
understand in the UK a lot of the people
who get written off as turfs as
trans-exclusionary radical feminists I
are actually saying that it should not
be up to the individual to Simply
designate themselves as female and hence
they have access to all female places
including prisons including dressing
rooms including Sports competitions but
rather that there should be some
policy that you know make sure that it's
not simply men masquerading as women who
have nefarious purposes is that accurate
or is that off
yeah that is accurate and I actually
think I I have said before that I think
sometimes the so-called turfs I'm very
supportive of turfs I think JK Rowling
who I would disagree with on 95 of
political questions especially brexit I
think she's been very heroic in this
situation she could she could easily
have a nice lovely Billionaire's life
but instead she keeps speaking out on
the thorniest issue of our time she
still has a very nice building other
than you know okay occasional Twitter
bombs and things like that but um but
yeah but yes I think um what those women
are saying what I've said to those women
rather is that I do think their emphasis
on the potentially nefarious desires of
um trans women biological males I think
they overemphasize that and I think a
better argument is not the safety one
although I perfectly understand why
women make that case but it's the
Privacy one it's the right of people to
a sphere in which you will not encounter
the the opposite sex for various reasons
because it's a space in which you are
going to be naked or in which you might
have to sleep like a shared dormitory
for example or in which you might be
imprisoned and you have no way of
getting out I think in those areas women
absolutely should have an expectation of
dignity and privacy and the trans
movement does threaten that but you said
earlier
um about religious extremism being on
the back foot
um which is true I think to a certain
extent although certainly in the west
yeah in Europe and the EU is worse than
the US by far in all of these counts but
yeah yeah of course and you know as as
you guys know very well we have had
executions for heresy by islamist
extremists here in Europe Samuel Patty
Charlie hebdo and and numerous others
um but the thing is you're right about
that traditional religions the old world
religions are not bossing people around
in the way that they used to in the west
but there are I think there are new
kinds of religion and I must say I think
the idea of a gendered soul the idea
that all of us you me everyone has a
soul whose gender might be different to
our biological encasing to me that is a
absurd religious idea it's one that is
not based in fact it's one that's not
based in any genuine attempt to
understand the truth of human experience
it is become a catechism that is and you
you risk being a social leper if you
don't bow down to it it has the feeling
of a religious idea it has the impact of
a religious idea in terms of wanting to
restrict how people can deviate from it
and question it and I think that's why
the preferred pronouns matters because
what some turfs will say is that when
they are
um cajoled or pressured or sometimes
forced to use a person's preferred
pronouns that's more than just being
polite that is acquiescence to what they
consider to be a modern day religion
that they don't believe in and just as I
don't think anyone should be forced to
say I love the Quran or I worship Jesus
Christ I also don't think people should
be compelled to say she about someone
who they think is male